CNN you know CNN they say they're the
most trusted name in news I'm starting
to suspect that may not be the case they
are really just terrible of course
yesterday five Israelis were killed in
the just the endless conflict that's
going on over there
so I don't even want to talk about that
because I know everybody agrees on the
Middle East so I even have to bring
anything up about that but I do want to
talk about CNN's coverage so here's a
clip and remember five Israelis were
killed in a synagogue see if you notice
anything strange here I there's no doubt
in my mind that the it's not even
murderers because animals don't behave
like this
with a butcher knife innocent people
while they pray okay so clearly that was
the mayor of Jerusalem and he was saying
synagogues several times I don't you saw
the chyron on the bottom said mosque
okay these things happen we've got
another clip from CNN later in the day
now among the wounded are two of the
police officers who arrived at the scene
one of them apparently in critical
condition now the Israeli officials
quickly coming out to condemn the attack
the israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu pointing the finger at hamas
but also at the President of the
Palestinian Authority Mahmoud Abbas
accusing him of incitement against
Israelis okay again a bit of an odd lead
there in that police shot killed two
Palestinians they shot the people that
had just killed the five other people
little bizarre what happened to the Jews
control the media
I thought the Jews control the media I'm
on the Internet I know what people are
saying about the Jews I guess they're
not doing a great job with the with the
media anymore yeah I know
Orthodox you know labove it devout Jew
but I I do know that a Jewish temple is
not called a mosque so I'm terrible at
games where it's like okay fine the we
find the thing that's missing I'm like I
know I'm gonna fail this I saw right
away that it's not called a Jewish
mosque yeah um so yeah what is going on
okay so I just want to be very clear I
don't want to make this about what's
going on in the Middle East at all or
about taking sides on the conflict there
any of that
this is purely I want to make this
purely about our media and CNN in
particular art either one of those
remotely how he's nobody fired
there was a half retraction Lee later in
the day because of another headline that
they screwed up it's a lower third
you know guys let's take a minute here
because I worked at a newsroom in the
newsroom there's a person in the corner
one of 30 people there and people are
shouting at them and it's their job to
literally on an ancient keyboard that's
like this big yeah
sit there and be like oh sorry let me
change that right now and they have to
type it really quickly and there's also
I don't know how CNN does it but they're
actually up to 36 hours of news a day
news cycle and so because of that
there's a lot that happens I think
there's tons of other stuff that CNN
does wrong I think in that second one I
still don't know what was wrong with it
because the headline they're talking
about that the two people that are
killed are the two terrorists that not
the five people that they just killed
right so another thing that has happened
in in in my interpretation of the media
is there's like a kind of news story
that comes along when it's news story
starts you kind of identify what kind it
is and and when you watch like a story
about Israel and Palestine a lot of a
certain number of people are like
alright let's dial in yeah but most
people are like oh okay so it's still
[ __ ] up there right okay I'll sit here
and wait until Blitzer tells me about a
cat that climbed up a tree yeah you know
what I I have to start by saying that
and it with literally no irony that I
really do appreciate you giving us a
little insight on the sad dude with the
big keyboard because I don't know
anything about that yeah yeah and that
that is really good to know however I am
so sick of people making excuses and I'm
not saying you I'm saying in general
people making excuses for this kind of
stuff like do your job if you find you
can't do it I get it you can't do it
somebody else will do it and if you did
it wrong and you screwed up apologize
I'm so I'm just so sick of that being
okay yeah so I basically agree with that
premise that yes it's yes this guy
probably gets paid pretty shitty it's a
36 hour news cycle in 24 hours I get it
it's high pressure it's live breaking
news it said
etc but the guy said synagogue like five
times and that little clipper three
times in that little clip it's like
shouldn't or shouldn't they have at
least come back to the anchor and him
been like actually but like more insight
to that what does happen what's wrong is
there's like this groan that emanates
through the newsroom from the first
person who noticed it from your room and
it's like and then there's like real
intense because during the in the
control rooms of all these news shows
it's like shouting and screaming like
this or can idea of it it really is like
get it alternate you've got a do redo so
if if it updated later to be fixed
you've got to understand that that's the
thing however I do I acknowledge it is a
mistake yeah and if you keep making
mistakes like this maybe it's a bigger
thing and that's the thing if it is if
the media is jew-run yeah wouldn't one
of the jew-run Jews tell the kid to
please change it from hasta synagogue
just because that's what it's called
you busy rolling in money and you throw
up maybe he couldn't hear over his large
horn